the second season of DC universes Titans
has come to a close
well the finale episode Nightwing it
doesn't end on the cliffhanger the first
season did it all so it doesn't fail to
raise more questions than it answers
Corey's powers proved less reliable over
the seasons last couple of episodes and
by Nightwing they disappear completely
she shocked Tyler and she's lost any
immunity to bullets when Deathstroke
shoots her early in the episode she
hasn't been able to use her energy
weapon since a previous episode and her
brief and embarrassingly futile attempt
to butter Denton Superboy with her fists
proves our abilities have completely
left her so far though we have no idea
what the cause of her power loss is
whatever has drained Corey's powers from
her like fire suddenly seems like the
most likely culprit
it isn't clear how Corey's sister could
have made it happen but evil alien
Queens aren't known for their lack of
resources the final scene of Nightwing
in which we see black fire arrived on
earth suggests that she has big plans
for her sister another possibility is
that her power loss is psychosomatic
like the fluctuation of spider-man's
powers in 2004 spider-man 2
[Music]
since the beginning of titans second
season curry has learned her sister has
stolen her throne her family has been
killed and finally Cori is forced to
kill her former lover honestly she
probably has way more stress than Peter
Parker ever did as soon as it was
confirmed at the end of the 11th episode
that Jericho was alive we've wondered
exactly how Dick Grayson planned on
saving his old friend killing
Deathstroke would presumably kill
Jericho as well unless he had another
body to jump into Rose solves a problem
in Nightwing by offering her body up to
Jericho to inhabit before finally
killing their sinister father now that
we know how Jericho is saved was left
asking exactly how this brother-sister
pair is going to live with their shared
body from what little we see of
Jericho's time when his father's body it
seems clear Deathstroke never willingly
gave up control to a son whereas Rose
lets her brother emerge right away so he
can talk to dick this drastic shift for
both characters isn't going to be easy
for now Jericho is likely grateful to
have any time in the world at all but
soon tensions are bound to rise between
him and Rose one moment in Nightwing
that likely raised a lot of questions
for fans it's a supposed death of Slade
Wilson aka Deathstroke Rose runs her
father through with her sword and dick
confirms he assassins death
dead
yeah not so fast dick in season two's
penultimate episode we see the extent of
roses healing powers she puts a muzzle
of a gun to her hands and blows a hole
through it only to have the flesh heal
moments later Rose inherited these
healing powers from her father so you
would think it would take more than a
sword to the chest to take him out for
good
perhaps it's a symbol of Slade's healing
powers not being quite as powerful as
they are in the comics but we're just
not convinced that we've seen the last
of him remember this isn't the first
time the Titans thought he was dead I
thought he was dead yeah we all did but
he's alive and well in San Francisco
maybe the Titans version doesn't have a
healing factor as beefy as Wolverines or
Devils but a sword through the chest
still seems far too easy of a way to die
for a man who single-handedly killed a
handful of famous Charon warriors before
beating the tar out of Donna Troy
earlier in season two some of the most
tragic circumstances to befall any of
the Titans a force upon God in season
two for the past few episodes Garth been
suffering from a mental reconditioning
courtesy of Mercy graves and Cadmus
laboratories when the right piece of
classical music has played gosh shifts
into his Tiger form and kills anyone
unlucky enough to be nearby in nights
Wayne rachel is able to cut through
canvases conditioning with her powers
and bring gar back to sanity but will it
stick
okay guard I wasn't that cool gals
brainwashing wasn't the sort of demonic
possession that many of the other Titans
have suffered at the hands of Trigon in
the season premiere it could be that
Rachel's powers healed the damage that
was done to gar completely but it could
also be that she was only able to break
him out of that particular violent
episode it seems likely that no one will
know for sure if gar is free and clear
from Cadmus is conditioning until the
next time he hears that same classical
music unfortunately if God does still
prove susceptible to the trigger with
Rachel infamous Kira the Titans may find
themselves unable to stop their friend
from going on a rampage in season two's
penultimate episode Jason Todd does not
react well to the revelation that Rose
was originally meant to be Deathstroke's
mole among the Titans in spite of Rosa
showing Jason her feelings for him
changed her loyalties it's too much for
the already troubled young Robin to bear
he leaves Rose and is completely absent
from the two climactic fights in light
wing we don't see him until he appears
on a motorcycle when the Titans transfer
Donna Troy's body to the famous Karen's
presumably both as a final show of
respect to his former teammates as well
as a way to let dick know not to expect
to see him anytime soon but has he gone
for good
Jason todd has a rocky history in the
comics and animated films the second boy
to wear woman's costume eventually dies
at the hands of the Joker and returns
later as a Red Hood Jason
yes we have no way of knowing if Jason
will go down similar roads in Titans but
while dick and Bruce might show the
minimum of respect for his decisions it
seems unlikely they won't at least keep
tabs on him if not outright tried to
bring him back to the fold
Donna Troy's death after the battle with
the brainwashed Superboy and Nightwing
came as a surprise for everyone
well there was fair to say that nobody
was more shocked than Donna herself
[Music]
but what we've seen from Donna would
suggest she should be able to survive
the injury that kills her moments before
Donna proves to be the only member of
the Titans able to actually trade blows
with Connor though she clearly doesn't
win the fight a person surviving even a
couple of unrestrained blows from
someone with the power of Superman was
suggested don't die easy it could be
that Donna's death is a setup for the
characters return sometime in season 3
or beyond racial leaves for temas Kira
specifically with the goal of finding a
way to bring down her back and it
wouldn't be the first time the character
was rescued from the land of the dead
the Donna Troy of the comics was
believed killed in the 2003 miniseries
Titans young justice graduation day only
for that to be a fake house she came
back to the Titans at a 2005 series
whose title might very well end up being
the name of a season three Titans
episode the return of Donna Troy
throughout Titans second season receive
Rachel's powers manifest in lots of
unpredictable ways we see her
unintentionally hurt both herself and
gah in her sleep with it perhaps most
shockingly
in fallen Rachel's abilities without her
knowledge or intent to bring a Stone
gargoyle to life that hunts down a new
friends abusive father by the end of
Nightwing we learn the summons I Rachel
Corey Donna and Dawn received to meet
Bruce Wayne at a diner in Nevada didn't
come from the real Bruce and everything
Corey has seen leads her to believe
Rachel's somehow unconsciously made it
all happen at the same sign the season 2
finale sees Rachel's powers evolved to
the point where she can use them to heal
she wakes gar from his mental
conditioning and with the touch of her
hands heals Corey's gunshot wound she
seems to think she may actually be able
to bring Donna Troy back from the dead
and was the plaintiff famous Kyra in
hopes of doing just that so what's going
on with Rachel's powers all we know for
sure is that Rachel's father is defeated
long before she has a chance to learn
the true limits of her abilities there
is Kyra might be the perfect place for
Rachel to learn more in the flashback
episode Aqualad
the og Titan Aqualad dies at
Deathstroke's hands in Jericho
we learned that Aqualad wasn't Slade
Wilson's real target it's revealed that
Jillian the old earth msq and museum
curator who seems to be part benefactor
and power mentor to Donna Troy were
Slade's quarry before his fateful battle
with Dick Grayson that ends with Jericho
death Deathstroke makes good on his
contracts and gets rid of Jillian what
we never learn is exactly why Jillian's
head was on the chopping block it isn't
difficult to imagine that a famous
Kieran like Jillian has made enemies
over the years but we don't get any
specifics
what's even more curious is that when
wintergreen first gives laid the details
of the contract in Aqualad he describes
it as easy the idea of targeting any
thermos Kieran and describing the job as
easy is insane
let's Luther yet to make an appearance
in Titans beyond pictures of him as a
child but Superman's arch nemesis still
has a powerful presence in the show's
second season in the episode Connor
Superboy learns his DNA is a combination
of Luthor's and Superman's the young
hero visits Luthor's elderly father and
Smallville and that doesn't take long
before we learn Luthor is behind the
experiments that created Conner toward
the end of Nightwing mercy graves is
more than a little concern to learn
Luthor is on the phone waiting to hear
about a failure
mr. Luthor it seems like Lex Luthor has
been groomed to be for season 3 what
Bruce Wayne was to season 2 well there's
no confirmation as of yet that Luthor
will appear in Titans go around it
doesn't seem likely that a billionaire
would allow his creation Superboy to
remain in the company of his greatest
enemies allies obviously Titans is about
the Titans and the integrity of the show
would suffer if suddenly Aquaman and
flash started reg Lee showing up on the
series still considering the events of
season 2 the question has to be asked
exactly where is the Justice League and
why aren't they getting more involved
by the end of Nightwing the history of
the Titans has seen the deaths of two
sidekicks Aqualad and Donna Troy another
sidekick Jason Todd is off the grid when
the woman must be well aware that the
same Deathstroke the Titans struggled
with this season is the one who murdered
a famous Kieran sisters for many years
earlier and then this Superman who by
now must know that a young man who is
emerging of his DNA and Lex Luthor's
exists and has gone on a number of
rampages in San Francisco so where are
they at the very least how could Wonder
Woman Aquaman and Superman and not get
more involved in the lives of the Titans
maybe Bruce Wayne acts as a buffer
between the league and the Titans and
off screen he might be urging his fellow
leaguers to not interfere but
particularly with what we know of when
the woman's warrior sense of Honor
emotion she would allow so many fellow
them as currents of fall without getting
involved more directly seemed strange
yeah you know what maybe dick just told
them all to stay away you know how he
can be
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]